[Music]
obviously all of you believe that your
dad would be a great president for this
country but as people with families how
do you feel about your dad becoming
president and how that would change your
life we're nervous about it I mean it's
it's one of those things we our lives
and pretty good as they are and this is
one of those things where we recognize
it's good for the country for my dad to
run but not necessarily he's good for us
and so we we're gonna try and keep our
lives as normal and as consistent as
they can possibly be over the next few
years well obviously I believe you
wanted him to run in the last campaign
were you guys reluctant about him
running this time we knew we're getting
into this time and so we're definitely
more hesitant I'm really reluctant I
didn't wanted to do it I tried to
convince him not to I think there are a
few a few of us that tried that and I
know you didn't but I just felt like you
know for us as a family this isn't the
best thing but as Josh said for the
country we think it's the right thing
you can probably tell I really love the
limelight so I was
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]